let's talk a little bit about kind of
the health crisis first and then we'll
get into the economic and policies and
things there the virus has shut down
entire societies for any countries etc
what's kind of your take on is the
health crisis weren't it in the sense of
the response we have on the health side
are we doing enough not enough kind of
how do you think through that yeah you
know there have been two other corona
viruses circulating through our economy
for on a regular basis their annual now
they're part of now our annual flu
season
so this corona virus is different in
that it's much more contagious but much
less deadly right so but when you put
those two together the much more
contagious it could it could hit a lot
more people much less lethal well maybe
it maybe it would be typical flu like
numbers which are anywhere from in the
United States 30,000 to 70,000 a year
now it looks like this one's going to
kill maybe 60,000 and I guess that's the
only number we can really count on
because we don't know how many people
really have been infected to people in
my and my sphere meaning my household
and household help have been infected so
I I think you know when books are
written about this we'll say okay well
okay that was an overreaction and yes
there there there there there are there
is a group of people that we must
protect when something is that
contagious even if it is less lethal and
in this case it was those with other
lung compromised diseases as well as
maybe people with high blood pressure
we're not sure about that one yet so and
you know a couple of things are
happening because of this virus first of
all we could not have sequenced it in
two days China sequenced it in two days
it took us five months to sequence the
SARS
is back in o3 so that that happened very
quickly
now China probably knew the sequence
my guess is well before they shared it
with us and if we had had it sooner we
would have understood it better but now
I think the other thing that we're
learning the tests that Abbott and
Cepheid which is owned by Danaher have
put out and I know Cepheid well because
I owned it before Danaher bought it and
really really good company they they're
actually based on old old-time PCR
technology it's old technology but what
got them to market as fast as they could
get to market were two things first of
all the sequencing of the virus we
understand exactly what it is and we
understand how it's mutating too that's
thanks to companies like Illumina and
then the second is synthetic biology so
if sequencing is the ability to read the
DNA of a virus synthetic biology is the
ability to write the DNA of a virus and
that company is twist it's one of the
most advanced out there not many people
know it but it's an amazing company if
they had not done those two things
Abaddon and Cepheid wouldn't have been
able to develop the test as quickly as
they have so that's good and I think the
other thing that's coming out of this
there are two other things from a
healthcare point of view after so the
SARS epidemic in o3 it circled the world
and then went poof it disappeared unlike
the other corona viruses I mentioned to
you and so what happened during SARS
that was a crisis I mean miss thing was
Mars was the lethality of SARS was at
least 10 percent Ebola was gosh it was
you know well above 50 percent and MERS
was somewhere in between there so again
this is much less deadly we don't know
how deadly it is because we don't know
how many
people have gotten it we'll know after
the fact so back then
SARS vaccines like there was so much
money pushed into the development of
vaccines it went poof and the funding
for vaccines dried up and then nobody
wanted to be in vaccines all these big
pharma companies sold their vaccine
companies because they were money pits
right now again and we're now that we
have new technologies like Madonna and
inovio and our tourists Moderne and our
tourists are based on RNA technology
ANOVA on DNA technology RNA we've never
seen at work if it works it's going to
be amazing and it'll be a very
profitable it's going to be a winner
take most you know because these
companies have developed libraries of
data and are going to be able to at
least get the licensing fees royalties
on all of this so I think Roy vaccine is
going to be a good place to be and the
other thing I think that this healthcare
crisis has done has is its providing a
lot of political cover what politician
is going to say no I don't want to pay
for testing for this that or the other
disease or I don't want to pay for
vaccines you know we're not going to put
that in the budgets no testing which has
also been it's considered historically a
commoditized business and and you have
two big companies dominating you have
quest and LabCorp in in the old world
and it's mostly commoditized even their
esoteric tests become commoditized just
because they're so big and now what's
happening is you get a company like in
vitae or gardens or Personalis some of
these you may have heard of what they
are doing I think this is gonna be a
winner take most world like so many in
the artificial intelligence world they
are gathering all the data they have
harnessed geneticists throughout the
world
you know these pools of geneticists and
they are beginning to develop tests
that are very precise and because they
can they've collected the right kind of
data so I think they're going to have so
much more political cover than they have
had historically it's always been an
area starved of funding because everyone
assumes it's commoditized it's not we
have the convergence of DNA sequencing
artificial intelligence and then CRISPR
gene editing which is going to not only
not only will we be able to create these
text tests so that to understand in a
very personal way how your DNA is
influenced right and and what is
impacted what's what your D how your DNA
is mutating they'll be able to figure
that out and then they'll be able to
pull therapies off the shelf or they'll
be able to design them with gene editing
to actually cure or reprogram your DNA
and cure the disease that's where we're
going yeah